what is going on everybody welcome to
another Python 3 basics tutorial as well
as the beginning of a miniseries for
SQLite SQLite is part of your standard
library with Python 3 so if you have
Python 3 you already have it so what is
SQLite SQLite is a lite version of SQL a
full version of SQL would be something
like MySQL or my sequel so SQLite as the
name suggests it's a lighter version so
unlike a full version like my sequel
SQLite you basically you can create and
use a server or a database rather
without a server so like a full version
of like my sequel for example is gonna
require you to set up a my sequel server
the client you're gonna have to set up
users and passwords and permissions and
all of these things whereas with SQLite
there are no users there's no
permissions there's no actual even
server or anything like that it actually
ends up going into a basic file a single
file so the next question people ask is
well why do we use SQLite over a flat
file for example it's difference well
SQL or an SQLite is gonna the file that
you're gonna create first of all it's
not like a flick to load in a flat file
let's say if you want to start
referencing data points and a typical
file you have to load that entire file
into memory
you could buffer through the file but if
you want to be able to query against
like say you want to find all data
points with a value of X you're still
gonna have to look through the entire
file so you're going to pull all that
file into memory whereas if you use
something like SQLite you won't have to
do that you're going to pull into memory
the bits that you need so it's it's
going to be useful that way also
SQLite your entire database will be a
single file and a lot of people at least
initially are a little confused about
what a database actually is a database
contains tables tables contain the data
most people think of a database as what
actually a table is so a database
contains a bunch of tables your tables
containing the data so with SQLite you
have an entire database that's contained
within a single file whereas if you were
just using flat files you would really
probably be you would have a file per
table basically so anyways
some of the other things SQLite is
better at is input-output for the same
reasons that it's better for like
efficiency when you're inputting and
outputting like for example to input
some data to a file you would have to
rewrite that entire file that's a long
operation also it's a little more taxing
on your actual hard drive itself whereas
with SQLite you just you're importing
that little file part instead of the
entire file all over again so it just
makes sense anyways there you go so if
anybody argued with you why SQLite is
the same as a flat file you now know
what to say so with that let's go ahead
and get started first of all to use
SQLite you're gonna import sqlite3
that's just the current version we are
using right now then what you'll do and
this is true with basically all forms of
SQL is going to you're going to define
your connection and your cursor all
throughout this tutorial and as we
continue you'll see that the cursor is
very much like the cursor you're
like--you're your computer cursor the
cursor does things okay now so what
we're going to do is we're going to find
the connection so Co n n is going to be
equal to sqlite3 connects and then we're
going to connect to some sort of
database we're going to connect a
tutorial DB this doesn't exist right now
and that's fine if SQLite attempts a
connection to a database that doesn't
exist it creates the database so simple
enough then we're going to define sweet
that is your cursor and that's just conn
dot cursor so now that you have those
we're ready we can connect to a database
but we don't have a table so a database
again just contains a bunch of tables so
first we need to create a table and when
we do that you're gonna see your first
SQL query basically so we're gonna say
define create table and in here we're
gonna see that execute so that's C for
the cursor the cursor does all the
executions of things and we're going to
say C dot execute and what we're going
to execute is the following statement
it's going to be create
great create table if not exists and
then you're gonna give the table and
name so it's basically whatever you want
to call it so you can call it what I
call it or you can call it whatever you
want so I'm gonna call it stuff to plot
because eventually what have I done
eventually we're going to plot so-so
stuff to plot and then in here you put
in your columns and the data types of
those columns so for example this first
column we're going to call eunuchs this
will be the UNIX timestamp and that's a
real number so real is like a Python
float so that's a real then we have
another column that's gonna be a date
stamp
that's text that's the data type then
we're gonna have a keyword and that will
also be a text and then finally we're
gonna have a value that'll be a real
number so that is our entire SQL
statement that just creates the table
for us if you'll notice that there are
some upper cases from some upper case
words and then there's some like lower
case stuff generally standards wise what
you do is use all caps for things that
are pure SQL and then you use regular
casing for things that are not SQL
commands and stuff like that so this is
part of the SQL it's a SQL command
create table if not exists you could you
would be able to do this without
capitalizing everything
you simply capitalize it to make it
easier for you to read later on so
because you don't have to capitalize it
what should that tell you that should
tell you that SQL is completely blind to
casing so if casing is important in your
database you have to handle that with
whatever programming logic you're using
because SQL is not gonna care about
casing so later on I'll show you guys
how you can you input some logic into
the stuff that you pull for your
database and you'll see that you know
with casing that's not really gonna
you're not gonna be able to use that
there you're gonna have to define that
logic outside of the SQL anyway moving
on that creates the table now we'll run
that at the very end we're now going to
cover how you can actually input data
into a database
so we're going to define data entry and
here it's going to be C dot execute and
again in all caps here insert into and
then stuff to plot is the name of our
table and then these are values and then
in the parentheses is where you input
the values and you would just input the
values in the exact order that you have
of columns right so the unix time the
date stamp the keyword and the value so
in our case what we're going to do is
you know you can pretty much make up
whatever you want I don't know it
depends what time it is right now but
for example you could put in we'll just
say for a timestamp 1 4 or 5 it doesn't
matter you can put whatever you want
here it's actually not that important so
in fact we'll just do this I'll just
make it up and then you'll put a date
like you would put you would put a date
stamp and in fact what we need to do it
let's put a double quote around this if
you need to you could put a triple quote
as well if you wanted to have something
that included quotes anyway so that's
your real number and then you would have
a date stamp will just say 2016 a 1 a 1
and then we had a keyword we'll just
call it Python and then we had a value
and we'll call that a 5 then so that's
inserting stuff in a stuffed apply it
now again it's just easy if you kind of
think of this as like a mouse cursor and
then you're like writing some stuff when
you write to a file what do you have to
do like if like say you type some stuff
into a text like a notepad or something
like that what do you have to do you
have to save it and then you can close
out so to save you do conduct commit so
anytime you modify anything in your
database you need to run a conduct
commit that's true with SQLite that's
true with my sequel and so on when
you're completely done you run a C dot
close that closes the cursor and it
conduct close now that's not essential
to change your database it's just
essential to close that connection stop
memory from being used and all that so
now we'll come on down here and finally
we can run
create underscore table and then we'll
run data entry and we'll run that okay
so it's already run it should be a
pretty quick operation and then what
I'll do is we can pull over where we're
working here and you see now we've got
tutorial dot DB now you may not have an
icon like that and you probably can't
even open it if you did it would look
like a bunch of goop but you can go to
this link there will be a link to this
specific tutorial in the description go
to there and you can find github
otherwise you can just Google for SQLite
browser and then you can scroll on down
to here and download the appropriate
version for your operating system
and then you should be able to open this
file you may have to associate the
program with that file but you you can
open that file now we can come over here
this database structure and stuff like
that we can just go to browse data and
sure enough this is our table we can see
these are other columns and we even have
a data entry here so then what we could
do is we could we could say now to let's
just change this and change the value to
an eight and we can rerun this create
table statement because we're using
Create table if not exists if you just
just have a create table statement you
would not want to rerun create table
that's gonna air for you but because
it's there it doesn't really matter we
can rerun it and it should be fine so
we'll rerun it real quick and that's
totally fine but normally you would just
want to run that once otherwise you're
just wasting your time anyways and then
once you're done there looks like I've
lost the there we go open this up it was
down here huh newb anyway there's our
new new data points okay so that's just
a really basic intro to SQLite in the
next tutorial what we're gonna be doing
is talking about how you can input
variables because so far we've input
like we've just written into the string
manually well if you're going to be
immediately entering stuff what's the
point of a database and programming in
general so in the next tutorial we're me
talking about is how to dynamically
start inserting things like variables
and all that so if you have any
questions or comments feel free to leave
them below otherwise state
- the nice tutorial thanks for watching